bit of breaking news to bring you
newcastle united football club have
sacked their manager steve bruce the
move was expected following the club's
305 million pound saudi-led takeover
earlier this month steve bruce of course
took charge of the club in its uh 3-2
premier league defeat at home to
tottenham on sunday that was of course
his 1000th game as a manager that was at
st james's park on sunday in a statement
on friday prior to the game the new part
owner amanda stabley said she wanted the
club to be patient and considered in
their approach and said that change
doesn't happen overnight steve bruce of
course a boyhood newcastle united
supporter but the fans had been on his
back a lot recently and very closely
associated with the former regime under
mike ashley among the rumored successes
for uh steve bruce by the way should we
went out to eddie howe the former
bournemouth manager is uh in hot
contention that he's one of the
favorites with the bookies right now so
breaking news there steve bruce sacked
as manager of newcastle united more than
that throughout the morning here on sky
news